écoutez-moi
ne laissez personne à l'intérieur entrer dans la maison en
ce moment
bonjour vous avez acheté du champagne oui bien sûr
je vous ai déjà dit que nous fêtons
ce soir nous sommes une famille je voulais que
nous soyons tous les trois ensemble ce sera
génial dans  l'été
parce qu'ils calment tes femmes
ça ira si tu ne le fais pas elles meurent s'il te plait je
ne veux pas voir ton visage nous sortons
je ne sors pas avec un masque
sur la tête où on va conduire prendre
sortez vos cartes de crédit et notez les
numéros d'identification personnels
Je ne négocie pas Je vous vois parler à
quelqu'un s'il atterrit pour demander de l'aide ou si vous faites
quelque chose de stupide
Je passerai un coup de fil en
attendant quelqu'un oh je suis désolé de
vous déranger si tard  mais les voisins ont
entendu quelqu'un crier je suis vraiment désolé
d'avoir dérangé les voisins
pourquoi nous avez-vous choisis pourquoi nous avez-vous choisis